Remember that components must
have a hyphen in them, so
let's name the component order-tracker.
While we're here,
let's create the service, too, and
let's call it order-manager.
The order manager service needs
to keep track of the active day.
We'll have the active
day default to Monday.
The service will also need to manage
the orders that have been placed.
I've created a menu selection object
that will hold the orders for each day.
So this is the data that
the service will need to manage.
Now we need to give it some
way to update this data.
The service needs to be able to
change which is the selected day.
It also needs to add an item
to the selected days meal.
And then it needs to be able to
remove an item from the menu.
Remember that we're extending
the service class with an object.
So inside a function we can directly
access one of the data properties.
Instead we have to use Ember's
this.get to access a property.
Or this.set to change it.
Here we have the order tracker
component and its template file.
We want the template to be
able to use this data, so
we need to make a connection between
the component and the service.
We use Ember to get the service and
stored in the order manager object.
It's all very readable, we inject
this service into this component and
refer to it by this name.
Now in the order tracker template we
want our users to know which day they're
picking food for.
So we reference
the orderManager object and
then the selectedDay
property off of the service.
Now let's add this component
to the application template.
And while we're here,
let's change the heading to make
it something more exciting.
I had to restart the server on the
terminal for the changes to take effect.
So if you don't see
the data from your service,
make sure to restart the server.
And here's the order tracker
template that's pulling
the data from the service.
We also want to display the menu item
that's been ordered for each day, so
let's add that to the template.
We need to display entries for
every meal, so I've added breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
We want this information for each day so
we need to loop over the list of days.
Let's use Ember's each in helper to loop
over the days storing the key as day and
the days order as menu order.
Let's use these variables
to print out the day and
the chosen menu item for a meal.
So here we're printing out the day.
And here are the menu items for
breakfast lunch and dinner.
And there we go.
We're showing a meal time for each day.
Now to add a button to each menu item,
so we can select it for
a specific day and meal.